it is black history month and there's a
quote that i love that i want to share
it says the world does not move without
black creativity and that is exactly
what the b is for brilliance black
brilliance i should say organization is
all about ceo and founder shawna wells
is here to tell us more welcome yes
thank you so much thanks for having me
oh my god i'm so excited to share this
so i want to make sure i read this
correctly okay you're calling this an
intentional and bold movement to affirm
uplift and center black innovation
genius and creativity you got it i love
that yeah that is beautiful and of
course it is a movement but it's also a
book yeah so introduce us to b is for
black players yeah i'll tell you we
founded the organization because we
wanted to change the narrative of
blackness in this country and we were
having so many conversations about
um black people from a deficit
standpoint and we thought at b is for
black brilliance what if we changed the
narrative what if we reclaimed and took
the narrative back and we did it
365 days a year 12 months of the year so
we wrote this book um it's titled b is
for black brilliance obviously yeah
please take a look hold on you guys have
got the okay i'm pulling this one over
okay while you talk about i'm gonna look
through yeah it's uh it's 26 individuals
i promise you that there are individuals
you've never heard of before because
we're more than just you know three
people that we hear about in black
history month and it's beautifully
illustrated by our illustrator kelly
marsh who's a black creative and the
whole organization is staffed by
brilliant black people oh my gosh this
is amazing that's you know it's this is
the start of a bigger opportunity for us
to share resources with caregivers and
kids to stimulate a conversation
absolutely and why why is it so
important to start with kids and
caregivers i mean you know ending racism
and and all of that it starts inside the
home yes yes and it starts with
caregivers right so as i'm writing this
book it was a healing process for me i
had the opportunity to explore hundreds
of thousands of names right we we landed
on 26 but there's millions of us out
there right 13 frederick douglass i mean
one of my favorites right yes um you
can't write a book about black history
without black black individuals without
putting frederick douglass in it i mean
exactly so we write this book and it's
an act of healing for me and i realize
that there's so much stuff that i need
to
think about and and adjust in my own
mindset so we asked the question what if
we started with kids before the mindset
is um
in their in their bones and body right
what if we start talking about
brilliance from age zero
what would it look like to reclaim and
to build a
a country where people accept the
responsibility of their brilliance and
they're able to move forward and build
new legacies of what it means to be
black in this country and in the world
that is beautiful so of course all of
our black history means something the
struggles as well but we want to amplify
the brilliance and the positivity yeah i
would say the struggle story often gets
told let's tell a new story let's tell a
new story i love that how can people get
more information on the book yes or get
the book yeah you can get the book at b
is for blackbillians.com you can also
get it on amazon but we prefer you come
visit us at our site because there's so
many more resources and opportunities
and you can follow us on all the socials
instagram linkedin um and facebook at bs
for black brilliance to learn more thank
you so much shawna thank you so much